inicia un camino de oportunidades para
nuestros pueblos con esas palabras los
presidentes de nicaragua y honduras
firmaron el tratado integracionista un
acuerdo que define a sus fronteras en el
mar caribe y el océano pacifico hoy los
pueblos hermanos de honduras en
nicaragua
estamos haciendo historia
historia
construyendo integración
basándose en el diálogo en los lazos de
amistad para promover la paz y el
desarrollo de la región el tratado busca
cumplir los límites marítimos que
estableció la corte internacional de
justicia en el caribe el 8 de octubre de
2007 según el texto la corte de la haya
instó a las partes a negociar de buena
fe la línea de limitación de mar
territorial remanente entre el punto de
la frontera terrestre establecido por el
laudo el rey de españa de 1906 y el
punto de la frontera marítima
establecido por la corte los límites en
el golfo de fonseca una zona que ambas
naciones centroamericanas comparten con
el salvador es uno de los puntos
cruciales del acuerdo sin embargo
todavía hace falta una negociación con
el gobierno salvadoreño y así poner fin
a los constantes conflictos con los
pescadores que traspasan las fronteras
de esta región el salvador también
está en la obligación de ponerse de
acuerdo
en este caso con honduras para delimitar
en el golfo tenemos acceso al golfo los
tres países
y los tres tenemos
salida hacia el mar
y eso hay que alimentarlo
para que se acaben los conflictos el
tratado entrará en vigor después de ser
ratificado por los congresos de
nicaragua y honduras y tras ser
registrado ante la secretaria general de
las naciones unidas